you're an attorney you've cancelled  people before that are facing serious  allegations you're being charged with  very serious crimes you're facing if  convicted on all of these charges up to  the rest of your life in prison are you  nervous  well of course I'm nervous are you are  you scared are you concerned I mean tell  us I guess as someone who again has a  history of representing people and now  you're on the other side facing some  serious charges I am nervous I'm  concerned I'm scared I feel terrible for  my family I feel bad for my friends most  people are sticking by me they believed  in me they know what I'm all about so  I've been very fortunate in that regard  but sure I'm nervous I'm scared I'm I'm  all those things and if I wasn't and  when I make a lot of sense